السجون والجراء ليسا
شيئين تراهما عادة سويًا ، لكن
التغيير الإيجابي هو برنامج في
سجن الولاية الشمالية الحالية في ديلانو يسمح
للنزلاء ذوي السلوك الجيد بتدريب
الكلاب وجعلهم مستعدين للتبني ، وأنا أعلم
أني أعني مساعدتهم معنا.  إعادة
المساعدة في إعادة تأهيل الكلاب وتحقيق
التوازن والهيكل في حياة الكلب ،
لكنه يفعل ذلك أيضًا مع حياتنا ،
كما يعلم هذا البرنامج التعاطف ،
فهم مسؤولون عن شخص آخر
يكونون مسؤولين عن
تغيير إيجابي آخر هو واحد من 32
برنامجًا  التي تشجع على السلوك الجيد
في السجن والمجموعة المعنية
بالتغيير الإيجابي تذهب إلى أبعد من مجرد
تدريب الكلاب التي ترعى حملة طعام
جمعت الأموال لإرسال طفل مصاب
بمرض عضال من ديلانو إلى
ديزني لاند
، ولكي نكون صادقين ، لا يمكننا تلبية
رغباتنا  بدون دعم مجتمعي من خلال
تبرعات المتطوعين وما إلى ذلك ،
وهي فرصة رائعة
رائعة لرؤية هذا
المجتمع يجتمع ليكون
لدعم هذه الرغبة ، كيف يعمل الأمر هو أن
النزلاء يمكنهم إنفاق ما يصل إلى مائة
دولار والحصول على وجبة محلية ، فإن الأموال
التي يخصصونها من أجل طعامهم ستخصص
لرعاية رحلة هذا الطفل إلى
ديزني لاند ، وأعتقد أنني تجاوزت الحد الأقصى
لإنفاق مائة دولار  على
الطعام الصيني وكان من المدهش جدًا أنه عندما
اكتشفنا أنه
سيرسل طفلاً إلى ديزني لاند ، لذلك يبدو الأمر
وكأنه مكسب للطرفين ، ستحصل على طعام جيد
وأيضًا يمكنك استثمار هذه الأموال في سبيل
سبب وجيه ولكن هناك  مشكلة
لا يمكنك المشاركة في هذه الأنشطة أو
البرامج دون أن يكون لديك سلوك جيد ، فأنا
لا أريد أن أتعرض لسلوك سيئ ولكن
لأنني لا أملك سلوكًا سيئًا ، فأنا
أكون في البرنامج ، وهذا أمر رائع حقًا
يعلم هؤلاء الرجال التعاطف
معنا.  اجعلهم مستعدين للعودة إلى
الشوارع ، حيث جمع النزلاء أكثر من 8
آلاف دولار خلف القضبان لمنح
صبي صغير أمنيته الأكبر لمقابلة
ميكي وميني ، إنه لأمر رائع حقًا أن نكون
قادرين على معرفة أنه يمكننا إحداث فرق إيجابي
في  مجتمعنا على الرغم من
أننا في السجن عندما ترى هذا النوع
من المجتمع يجتمع معًا للقيام
بشيء غير أناني ،
فإنه يكون أكثر إلهامًا